as an expansion that is a couple of
areas and one boss fights short of being
truly extensive the old hunter still has
a good deal of tests for hardened
blood-borne and souls enthusiasts the
old hunters like a main game is replete
with difficult encounters especially
against hunters and fearsome bosses the
enemies that lurk along yar nums dark
pathways are as ruthless as any you
would find in the main game the new
bosses here greatly complement the large
roster from the main game and they're
more imaginatively designed than what
you can find in the chalice dungeons to
these new bosses bring unexpected
tactics to the fight making it hard to
rely on your existing strategies a
couple foes such as the grossly deformed
Ludwig fight back against ridin through
tactics such as rolling towards your
opponent so don't be surprised if they
body slam you and you least expect it
the old hunters is blood-borne from
another time in place and with more
difficult bosses and confounding stories
to unravel it's also a great compliment
to the original gruesome adventure
you